la situation est critique pour les
derniers combattants ukrainien à
marioupol alors vous l'avez dit du côté
de la russie et notamment du ministère
de la défense on a expliqué qu'un
certain nombre de combattants quelques
milles s'était rendu cette thèse a tout
de suite été réfutées côté ukrainien
mais il est clair que la situation est
très difficile les combattants ukrainien
qui résistent sont dans une zone d'un
complexe métallurgique qui s'appelle
asos talent c'est tout simplement énorme
c'est une petite ville et donc il y a
encore des combats intenses des combats
qui ressemble à de la guerre il ya
urbaine mais c'est vrai que les
ukrainiens sont encerclés ils ont de
moins en moins de munitions et la
situation semble de plus en plus
critique alors ce chiffre a évoqué par
les russes concernant la reddition de
quelques mille hommes c'est peut-être
évidemment de la propagande mais en tout
cas la situation est bel et bien
critique et puis en face côté ukrainien
on a expliqué que quelques 1500 corps de
soldats russes se trouvaient dans la
morgue denis pro une façon de dire que
du côté russe il ya aussi un très grand
nombre de victimes côté ukrainien on
reconnaît la possibilité qu'il puisse y
avoir des redditions dans des zones de
combat mais certainement pas myope d'un
coup en tout cas on réfute cette idée
côté ukrainien en tout cas je peux vous
dire que la situation à marioupol est
extrêmement critique dans la mesure où
si annie prompt à croiser un certain
nombre de réfugiés qui ont fui cette
zone terrible où il y a eu des des
milliers et des milliers de morts tous
racontent l'enfer sur terre
racontez nous un peu plus ce que ces
réfugiés vous disent ils sont prises en
charge ils trouvent un refuge ici à ni
pro
alors il trouva refuge admis pro un
certain nombre d'entre eux restent ici
quelques jours en attendant d'avoir un
point de chute un peu plus à l'ouest
plus en sécurité ils viennent je vous le
disais de mario paul ou encore de 2 nex
de lougansk à kharkiv aussi ces derniers
jours il ya eu des frappes extrêmement
importante qui ont touché des zones
civiles il ya donc des gens qui viennent
de cette région de kharkiv alors ici il
ya un certain nombre de personnes qui se
mobilisent pour leur venir en aide pour
tenter de leur apporter des produits de
première nécessité pour leur offrir à
manger il ya même tout à l'heure nous
sommes allés dans une petite structure
qui accueille des enfants parce que il
ya aussi beaucoup d'enfants souvent
traumatisés qui ont fui ces zones de
guerre
li pro pour la plupart de ces gens dès
qu'une étape pour partir ailleurs alors
aujourd'hui on a vu qu'il était très
difficile d'atteindre ni pro parce que
les frappes sont tellement intenses
notamment dans la région du dombass
qu'il y a qu il n'y a pas de convois
humanitaires qui a pu se déplacer
aujourd'hui et ce qu'ils soient arrivés
ces derniers jours sont arrivés au
compte-gouttes